c'est quoi cette histoire qui si vous
êtes arrivé vous très simple en 2003
j'avais acheté d un immeuble
oui quand même nos lois c'était en 2003
alors en fait mon agent m'a appelé en
2003 le acheté un jet gratte-ciel
animaux achetés 1 et me voilà et comme
un détail je lui avais une vingtaine
d'appartements de dans un bel immeuble
quand même et avec ge avait investi une
certaine somme d'argent dedans et en
fait
l'immeuble que je pensais avoir acheté
que je pensais être un immeuble en bonne
et due forme c'était loi malraux
d'ailleurs pour faire des économies
d'impôts ça va ça m'a en fait coûté une
fortune parce que de 15 ans après non
seulement il me vaut pas grand chose si
ce n'est rien on n'arrive pas à le
vendre et surtout pas j'ai du pays un
crédit et à los angeles
non je comprends la logique alors
j'avais eu du pif encore c'est un peu ça
c'est un peu comme tout dans ma vie
j'avais a fait citer à tulle
forcément tu le sais pas monsieur donc
voilà donc c'est bon quand cav à vous
avez un immeuble à tulle j'avais un
immeuble qu'il a été saisi entre temps
mais je suis toujours en procès mais
savez quoi à tulle alors là j'ai plus
rien l'ag que des dettes
on savait match aller ce qu'on dit ah tu
de la turballe à tuiles qui les verra
plus les pôles de monture mais il fait
des bourses donc son procès copains
d'accords dont vous avez fait arnaquer
donc ce n'est pas sa capitale aussi
alors ça je les revends du jeu vous avez
acheté un hôpital à la ville aussi la
tchaux and hope et hulene on dit j'ai de
super j'ai acheté un super truc et des
besoins pour défiscaliser s'est plaint
de respirateurs dans les hôpitaux et
tout ça c'est des trucs dans ce plan
nous avons acheté auprès de très très
bonnes un investissement peu de super
mais dis moi tu es bon tu sais si tu es
donc notre vie quand tu arrives tu
achetais hôpital ouais c'est vrai mais
jeudi un bond de la veille a pas un mec
qui refait des yeux sévère marionnaud
petacchi se faire arnaquer tu avais des
gens qui te conseiller ou tu te
conseillait le conseiller tout seul
comme un grand con way
en face on peut pas des renards tout
heureux lingots en soi yeux vous êtes
heureux trésor j'ai des puces potec que
si vous aviez gagné beaucoup d'argent
vous ne seriez pas là ratu le statut non
non non mais je ne désespère pas que
c'est une blague à part c'est on est
plusieurs dans cette histoire il n'y a
pas que moi actuelle il ya bouvier des
footballeurs enfin les très nombreux à
avoir mis de l'argent et je pense ça va
faire un peu de bruit dans quelques
temps mais je crois qu'on s'est fait
escroquer par voilà un gars il ya une
banque qui a noté revient dans le sud